en este vídeo vamos a hablar acerca de
la suma y la diferencia de la varianza
de dos variables aleatorias por lo tanto
voy a definir las voy a suponer que
estas variables aleatorias van a ser
equis y entonces x son para no olvidarlo
dos variables aleatorias que son
independientes dos variables aleatorias
independientes eso es muy importante ya
que si no fueran independientes no
ocurriría a todos lo que vamos a
construir bueno voy a retomar algunas
cosas que ya habíamos visto en otros
vídeos pasados para ello poder construir
la suma en la diferencia de la varianza
lo primero es que el valor esperado de x
es igual a la media de x y de una manera
completamente análoga para que como son
independientes el valor esperado de la
variable aleatoria es igual a la media
de james recuerden que el valor esperado
de una variable aleatoria es lo mismo
que la media de esa misma variable
aleatoria y bueno es también siguiendo
con el recordatorio qué pasa con la
varianza de una variable aleatoria
de equis a pues esto era igual al valor
esperado de quien de la diferencia entre
la variable de la teoría x menos la
media de x esto elevado al cuadrado el
valor esperado de todo esto que también
denota vamos con sigma cuadrada sin ma
cuadrada de varianza pero de la variable
aleatoria x es decir sigma cuadrada
subíndice x es lo mismo que el valor
esperado de la diferencia de x en la
variable aleatoria x menos la media de x
elevada al cuadrado y de hecho va a ser
lo mismo para la varianza de ella y va a
ser el valor esperado de la variable
aleatoria y que menos la media de esa
variable aleatoria y en este caso ye
perdón
aquí lo voy a corregir ahora si la
varianza de la variable aleatoria es
igual al valor esperado del cuadrado de
la diferencia de la variable aleatoria y
menos la media de la variable aleatoria
y esto lo denota vamos con sigma
cuadrada subíndice ya muy bien pero para
encontrar la varianza de la suma de
estas dos variables la torias
primero voy a empezar a definir una
nueva variable aleatoria esta variable
aleatoria va a ser igual a z y la voy a
llamar x + esperen voy a ponerlo todo de
los calores correspondientes x era
amarillo entonces z es igual a la
variable del autor ya x sumado a la
variable aleatoria y y bueno qué va a
pasar lo primero que me voy a preguntar
es qué pasa con el valor esperado de z
es decir el valor esperado de x margen y
bueno una de las propiedades del valor
esperado es que el valor esperado de la
suma de dos variables aleatorias es
igual a la suma de los valores esperados
de cada una de las variables aleatorias
y aunque este vídeo no es el enfoque
para demostrar esta propiedad es muy
fácil probarla deberían de intentarlo
por lo tanto el valor esperado de z es
igual al valor esperado de x más el
valor esperado de iu o dicho de otra
manera la media de la variable del autor
ya z es igual a la media de la variable
aleatoria x más la media de la variable
aleatoria
y bueno ahora la pregunta es ocurrirá lo
mismo para la diferencia de variables
aleatorias
bueno para esto voy a definir como la
variable la teoría x menos la variable
aleatoria y ahora bien quién es el valor
esperado de a pues bueno por definición
es el valor esperado de x menos y bueno
esto por la propiedad de la izquierda es
lo mismo que el valor esperado de x más
el valor esperado de menos que por
cierto es lo mismo que el valor esperado
de x menos el valor esperado de ye y
bueno esto es lo mismo que la media de
la variable aleatoria x menos la media
de la variable aleatoria y que por
cierto todo esto es lo mismo que la
media de la variable delator ya que
acabamos de definir la variable
aleatoria a bueno espero que hasta aquí
vayamos muy bien ahora vamos a
preguntarnos qué pasa con la varianza
primero voy a pensar en la varianza de z
es decir lo que voy a buscar ahorita es
la varianza de la suma de dos variables
aleatorias para esto quiero recordar lo
que acabamos de ver justo ahorita lo que
vimos es que el valor esperado de z era
igual al valor esperado de x más el
valor esperado de y justo aquí lo
tenemos la media de la variable delator
ya z es lo mismo que la media de la
aleatoria x más la media de la variable
aleatoria y es decir el valor esperado
de una suma de variables aleatorias es
igual a la suma de los valores esperados
por lo tanto siguiendo esta lógica quien
sería la varianza de zeta vamos a
escribirlo y vamos a irnos con un poco
de cuidado aunque realmente ustedes ya
pueden suponer quién es la varianza de
esta nueva variable aleatoria que
acabamos definir la varianza de z a
quien sería igual
marian za de z pues esto es lo mismo que
la varianza de x + james pero si el
valor esperado de la suma de dos
variables aleatorias es la suma de los
valores esperados de cada una de las
variables aleatorias y además observamos
que la varianza de una variable
aleatoria está definida como el valor
esperado de la diferencia de la variable
aleatoria menos su media elevada al
cuadrado suena muy lógico pensar que si
tenemos una nueva variable doctor ya z
su varianza va a ser igual a la suma de
las varianzas es decir la apariencia de
z es lo mismo que la varianza de x
más la varianza de james y esto es muy
claro porque recuerden que la que el
valor esperado de x + era louis aunque
el valor esperado de x más el valor
esperado de la variable aleatoria y es
decir la varianza en zeta o dicho de
otra manera usando la otra anotación
sigma cuadrada subíndice zeta es igual a
ser más cuadrada subíndice x mayer esto
por definición pero por lo que acabamos
de ver esto es lo mismo que sigma
cuadrada de x subíndice x más sigma
cuadrada subíndice que es decir la
varianza en x más la varianza en bien y
bueno ya que tenemos la varianza de una
suma de variables aleatorias que pasará
con la diferencia de variables
aleatorias podemos llegar a lo mismo o
suponer lo mismo y bueno las respuestas
que no hay que tener mucho cuidado
porque no es tan obvio o tan fácil
suponer que la varianza de una
diferencia de variables aleatorias es la
diferencia de cada una de las varias
vamos a verlo con cuidado y vamos a
corregirlo
-quienes sigma cuadrada subíndice a
bueno por definición es sigma cuadrada
subíndice x menor
y recuerden que la variable aleatoria a
estaba definida como la diferencia de la
variable aleatoria de x menos la
variable aleatoria ayer ahora para
utilizar la propiedad de la varianza de
una suma de variables aleatorias voy a
escribir esta misma varianza de la
siguiente forma como signo cuadrada de x
+ - y utilizando propiedades de los
signos esto lo hago porque ahora si
podemos utilizar que la varianza de una
suma de variables aleatorias es lo mismo
que la suma de las varias as es decir
sigma cuadrada subíndice x + - yen lo
puedo escribir como sigma cuadrada
subíndice x + sigma cuadrada subíndice
menos james y ahora viene la pregunta
correcta de este vídeo a quien es
equivalente sigma cuadrada subíndice
menos si yo puedo responder la varianza
de menos yo ya tengo la solución de este
problema espero que hasta aquí vaya todo
claro porque es justo en este momento
donde voy a hacer el truco de este vídeo
para yo poder calcular la varianza de
menos voy a utilizar la definición de
varianza es decir es el valor esperado
del cuadrado de la diferencia de la
variable aleatoria
- el valor esperado de la variable
aleatoria menor yo solamente estoy
utilizando la definición de varianza y
bueno vamos a simplificar un poco más
todo este asunto lo primero que se me
ocurre es actualizar un -1 para que me
quede una suma en lugar de una
diferencia es decir voy a obtener menos
1 elevado al cuadrado esto por la
propiedad de dos números elevados al
cuadrado menos uno elevado al cuadrado
que multiplica a la variable aleatoria
más el valor esperado de la variable
aleatoria menos ojo del valor esperado
de la variable a teoría menos jet todo
esto elevado al cuadrado ya esto hay que
sacarle el valor esperado ojos dese
cuenta que como factores es solamente el
menos uno me queda el valor esperado de
la variable aleatoria menos y por lo
tanto de hechos la pregunta que quiero
resolver ahora que hace el valor
esperado de la variable aleatoria menos
y desde cuenta que esto es muy fácil de
probar que es menos el valor esperado de
la variable de atonía y es decir el
valor esperado de menor que es igual a
menos el valor esperado de iu y con esta
observación y además cancelando en menos
al cuadrado que me da 1 obtengo que la
varianza de menos y es igual al valor
esperado del cuadrado de la diferencia
de que menos el valor esperado de g es
decir estoy sustituyendo que el valor
esperado de menor y es igual a menos el
valor esperado de ye que por cierto ya
se dieron cuenta esto que tengo aquí es
ni más ni menos que la varianza sub 26
james
acabo de utilizar la definición de
marian za y acabo de probar que la
varianza de menos y es igual a la
varianza de y por lo tanto ahora si
puedo escribir qué pasa con la
diferencia de variables aleatorias
cuando yo calcula su varianza la
varianza de x menor que es lo mismo que
la varianza de x más la varianza de g es
decir con lo que acabo de probar acabo
de sustituir a la varianza de menos por
la varianza de g y ahora si ya obtuve
qué pasa con mi varianza de la
diferencia de variables aleatorias que
se dan cuenta por cierto la varianza de
la suma de variables aleatorias es lo
mismo que la varianza de la diferencia
de variables aleatorias que por cierto
es lo mismo que la varianza de
más la varianza de la otra ojo recuerdan
que todo lo que acabamos de construir lo
construimos para variables aleatorias
que fueran independientes la una de la
otra y bueno para finalizar quiero
mencionar que hubo dos datos importantes
en todo esto lo primero es que si
tomamos la media de la diferencia de dos
variables aleatorias esto es la
diferencia de cada una de las medias es
decir la media de x menos y es igual a
la media de x menos la media de lo
segundo muy importante que acabamos de
descubrir es que si nosotros tomamos la
varianza de la diferencia de dos
variables aleatorias es la suma de cada
una de las varias de mis variables
aleatorias no la diferencia es la suma
de cada una de ellas espero que todo
este procedimiento no haya sido muy
confuso para ustedes y si lo fue ya
tienen dos herramientas que pueden
utilizar